bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
à 6 ans par les sports le talk est
conservée comme vous le savez à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
vous connaissez pour la démission il y
aura des débats des analyses et des
duels
il y aura quatre chroniqueurs en plateau
aujourd'hui quatre chroniqueurs qui sont
prêts à en découdre présentation en
musique on commence à droite c'est le
spécialiste cyclisme de cette émission
nous n'avons pas choisi n'importe qui
puisqu'il est tout neuf champion
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste master
section du monde également le pistard de
lisier sur le venus en vélo
même si il n'avait pas d'essence dans sa
voiture tu as fait c'est bien logé de
l'essence même du variétés avec lui vous
allez derrière très bien très bien
c'est vrai vous serez venu à un cheveu
du vent mais oui oui ou plus 50 km il
pleut pas aujourd'hui tout va bien
parfait bon on va voir si vous êtes
prêts dans cette émission en passe à
notre deuxième chroniqueur musique
il est l'entraîneur de l'équipe seniors
du club de rugby de plaisir ses coups de
gueule dans cette émission sont devenues
légendaires à tel point qu'on est en
train d'imaginer une statue à son
effigie pour remplacer celle de louis
xiv à versailles jean miss est avec nous
bonjour bonjour genlis c'est une rumeur
ou pas mais il va falloir qu'un menu du
mode du matériau on repasse à droite
musique il est le président de l'étoile
sportive de trappes s'est lui aussi un
monument dans les yvelines il est le mvp
des présidents le ballon d'or des
dirigeants moustapha larbaoui est avec
nous aujourd'hui nous fait l'honneur de
venir sur ce bateau en forme est sympa
c'est un honneur pour moi et bonjour à
tous les téléspectateurs
il ya du beau monde sur ce plateau ouais
je trouve aussi me régulièrement
règlement bien entouré ce ce plateau on
repasse à gauche musique et l'entraîneur
des bélascain de versailles n'a peur de
rien il est habitué à réaliser des
plaquage cathédrale dans cette émission
qui aurait pu lui valoir quelques
suspensions guillaume nero 9 lite avec
vous en soyez gentils avec elle alors
vous êtes à vue pendant
mission de une de même de deux émissions
m vous avez en tout cas à vue c'est
gentil merci nous a tous inspiré ou
safari
les quick de l'homme tu peux aller on va
sortir peu ce soir on va passer
maintenant au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de la
coupe de france de cyclisme sur piste
qui s'est déroulée au vélodrome du
combat de boxe de l'élan courtois à
marvin petit mais tout de suite coup de
projecteur sur la montée du chesnay
versailles
en basket le chesnay-versailles arraché
à 100 tickets pour monter à 17 années en
nationale 2 ce dimanche les filles de
vinko à bardigues sont dominées
escaudain sur leur terrain 65 à 56 lors
du dernier match des play off devant
plus d'une centaine de supporters
premier de la saison régulière avec une
seule défaite le chesnay-versailles
termine également sur la première marche
du podium des playoffs les yvelinoises
affiche donc un bilan de seulement 2
défaites en 26 matches disputés cette
saison on écoute la réaction des
joueuses de l'équipe
cette année on a fait un très très très
belle équipe on était fort mais c'est
toujours très très difficile de monter
donc on a monté parce que on a travaillé
très dur voilà c'est ça on est on avait
une très très très tard une équipe très
fort ce papier mais il faut montrer trop
tout ça sur le terrain
notre force c'est l'équipe c'est
vraiment l'équipe parce qu'on on à se
trouver restent soudés entre eux c'est
un peu difficile
et c'est ce qui fait qu'on gagne ce soir
les joueuses du chesnay versailles
remonte donc un an après être redescendu
faire l'ascenseur et il a un avantage ou
un inconvénient pour la saison prochaine
vous votez oui ou non
oui pourquoi pas d'âge oui pour l'
avantage vert pour l' avantage rouge
pour l'inconvénient dit que j allais
entre et vous mustapha gens vont
commencer contre moustapha aux gens
comment les gens allaient jusqu'aux
mains des gens ben non c'est pas un
avantage parce que faire l'ascenseur ça
déstabilise et lendemain le groupe pour
moi à part si vraiment si c'est que la
deuxième fois voici mais effectivement
si la saison dernière elle était en
nationale 2 elles descendent et que et
réussissent à remonter directement en
nationale 2 et que là après la
mayonnaise prend ok mais si c'est pour
comme des clubs que je connais mon
honneur rugby qui font systématiquement
l'ascenseur entre deux divisions ça perd
un petit peu de crédibilité et surtout
au niveau du groupe on n'arrive pas à
garder les joueurs quoi hélas je sais
pas mais j'ai pas s'ils ont vraiment un
groupe très très unie comme elle dit et
je sais pas s'ils changent pas souvent
de deux joueuses parce que justement
c'est ce que c'est quand un club fait
l'ascenseur comme ça c'est ce qu'on
constate souvent quoi il ya beaucoup de
joueurs qui partent et d'autres qui
reviennent parce que je donne à ne pas
stabilisé un groupe ça alors en fait moi
je réponds à la question parce que je
n'ai pas trop trop bien comprise et moi
je réponds à la question pour dire que
c'est favorable mais en fait je n'ai pas
compris
visiblement à l'abri blement le genre
pour moi visiblement gens non plus
l'occident s'est jamais bien de faire
l'ascenseur tout le monde pourra le
comprendre simplement ma réponse elle se
situe sur un point c'est qu'après tout
ils sont remontés
donc je ne sais pas si c'est un avantage
de faire l'ascenseur mais ce que je vois
surtout c'est qu'elles sont en capacité
de montée après il ya des problèmes
internes qui font que
la difficulté à rester maintenus bas
finalement laura ils ont pas trouvé les
ressources l'an dernier mais elles ont
surtout trouvé les ressources pour
remonter et c'est ça que je retiens
seulement souvent on parle de la sauer
on a été mal compris la question elle
m'a soumise à débat ici sur le fait de
savoir si c'était grave de monter alors
qu'on n'était pas prêts de monter si
éventuellement l'équipe n'était pas
suffisamment costaud est ce que la
chance n'a pas souri
moi je considère qu'à partir du moment
où on monte il n'y a pas de secret quand
on monte c'est que vraiment on a trouvé
les ressources
après le maintien c'est autre chose mais
faire l'ascenseur tout le temps je
répète
j'avais pas compris les donc là je
rejoins votre ami évidemment que faire
l'ascenseur en permanence c'est une
incohérence
d'ailleurs ça n'a même pas de sens cela
étant je garde quand même cette idée que
quand on est en capacité de trouver les
ressorts pour monter ça reste un élément
dynamique et est favorable mais
j'aimerais savoir s'il va demander
laquelle jouaient ce qui est inquiétant
c'est que puisque inquiétant c'est
qu'apparemment il n'y a pas beaucoup de
joueuses formées au club si ce n'est
aucune je crois dans le quasiment que
senior et ça c'est quand même embêtant
pour la c'est sympa quand c'est manquer
parce que quoi qu'il arrive la montée ça
crée un groupe ça crée une émulation et
cetera par contre les années où ça
descend s'il n'y a pas de filles qui
sont vraiment attachés au club c'est
plus compliqué et ils peuvent les garder
peut-être un peu que je sais pas si
elles sont payées ou pas mais peut-être
qu'un peu d'argent je sais pas mais je
sais pas dans la presse
peut-être mais ouais c'est coupet
recenseurs la l'ue herman surtout quand
y'a pas que les travaux ne suis pas
assez compliqué quoi sauf que sauf que
ça va rester attachés simplement aux
groupes et aux jouets est ce qu elles
sont est-ce qu'elles viennent du club
est ce que je vais faire mon club est ce
que c'est
des recrutements ou pas il ya aussi à
regarder comment ça se passe en interne
et là je pense surtout aux clubs
dirigeants du club un peu malheureuse à
la parole je veux juste avoir entendu
sur dire que le basket c'est ma grande
passion du sport en salle des sports en
salle ça me ça me connaît bien
non voilà ce que je veux savoir c'est
combien de temps ça faisait combien de
temps qu'elle était en nationale 2
descendre en nationale 3 voilà si ça ne
fait dix ans qu'elle y était que de la
descente c'est un accident puisque vous
dites que c'est ça l'art excellent
deuxième fois voilà c'est un accident
eh bien elles ont su rebondir après une
spirale négative qui était qui était le
cas la saison dernière
donc maintenant on va les suivre l'année
prochaine pour voir si si elle arrive à
la ce a conservé la là a conservé la
saison avec un ascenseur pas tous en
même temps après il faut dire qu'il faut
un s'ils veulent se maintenir en
nationale 2 je pense qu'il faut qu'elles
recrutent toute façon obligatoire est
dominé israël ont perdu deux agents
perdu 340 division elles ont perdu deux
matches et être en 26 matchs en national
c'est vrai mais c'est pas parce que tu
as en même temps pas de l'harmattan est
vraiment sur une spirale positive de
victoire donc donc du coup ça peut ça
peut sourire ça peut sur une année
prochaine et voilà stabiliser ce fait
cet effectif
faites-le renforcer n'est pas non plus
voilà d'une de nous deux joueurs épaules
de choses
ces deux exemples dernière ils n'étaient
pas soit maintenu que les mêmes
effectifs
il faut renforcer l'avenir peut-être je
connais pas la marche entre la zonation
international de hong kong une énorme
je vous rappelle mais incomplet parce
que je sais pas le chesnay versailles a
perdu un match en play-offs devait
gagner les trois suivants pour monter
justement en nationale 2 elles ont gagné
les trois matches du coup peut-être que
ça crée une dynamique de groupe
je suis bien sûr c'est une évidence mais
on sait tous que enfin dans tous les
sports je pense pas au niveau amateur
quant au monde d'une division il ya
quand même le niveau de jeu augmente
quoi que ce soit physique soit technique
ce soir la reine de la vitesse
et peut-être que les joueuses
d'aujourd'hui de nationale 3 aujourd'hui
elle se balade organisée à troyes ça
peut arriver mais quand monte en monte
en nationale 2 c'est un peu plus
compliqué du coup il faut peut-être
recruter des dps festival se met en fête
en nationale 2
recruter des joueuses d'expérience
nationale 2 qui ont ce vécu nationale 2
après suivre on va les suivre de près
les prochaines
et puis et puis on va leur souhaiter de
se maintenir en nationale 2
la saison prochaine parce que j'aurai
assez clair comment quiconque y compris
la question j'aurais comparé le vélo
donc on va parler justement de vélo
après cette page basket on passe au
cyclisme un thème qui va pas faire
plaisir à notre chroniqueur yann
dujarrier et ça ne va pas très bien pour
justement les cyclistes
c'était une grande première au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
première manche de la coupe de france
fait mieux organisée par la fédération
française de cyclisme était programmé ce
week-end dans l'enceinte yvelinoise au
total une centaine de pistard élite
juniors et cadets à participer à
l'événement parmi les têtes d'affiché on
retrouvait les pistards de l'équipe de
france kevin sireau et michael d'almeida
et françois pervis le britannique jason
kenny triple champion olympique a
également fait le déplacement pour les
cyclistes qui partait aux jo c'est avant
tout une préparation on écoute les
réactions première compétition depuis
les championnats du monde à londres au
mois de mars
donc ça permet de faire un point de
passage ce évalué par rapport au premier
cycle d'entraînement qui qui va se
terminer
testé également des vélos des braquets
donc voilà c'est une étape une étape
vers rio dans la construction des cycles
d'entraînement c'est de la préparation
les rendez vous importants on peut pas
se permettre d'arriver toute la saison
sur des rendez vous importants
on a deux trois rendez-vous important
dans la saison et là c'était de la
préparation tout simplement clodine
parisse catherine on est venu à paris
parce que c'est une compétition
européenne face à l'une des meilleures
équipes du monde c'est juste un rendez
vous à mi chemin entre les championnats
du monde et les jeux olympiques
on essaye de warwick on a vu qu'il y
avait énormément de pistard qu'ils
allaient partir aux jo cette coupe de
france est elle une bonne préparation
pour les jo vous votez oui ou non ont un
petit duel entre guillaume et yann c'est
parti guillaume vous commencez ça va
être rapide moi je pense que non parce
que je pense qu aucun mec n'a coché
cette date dans le calendrier de
préparation et qui viennent juste là
pour voilà parce qu'il faut venir ici la
coupe de france est et qui sont pas du
tout au niveau je pense à leur maximum
donc je pense que ça n'a aucun intérêt
on est complètement d'accord maintenant
même si latine là dessus on est d'accord
maintenant c'est un peu plus long que
d'habitude je fais un petit peu plus
maintenant l'intérêt il est pour le
public pouvoir voir courir jason
qu'henning kévin sireau et françois
pervis voilà que des gars qui ont tous
des titres de champion du monde matière
larigot quelques champions olympiques
ben voilà c'est quand même très très
beau oui en effet ça va un poil moins
vite que sur un championnat du monde
comme ça a pu être le cas en février
il ya très peu de coureurs qui sont
passés en dessous des 10 secondes sur le
200 m chrono alors que aux championnats
du monde la qualification se jouait en
dessous du en dessous d'eux en dessous
du 10 mai
faut dire qu'on parle un petit peu de
vélo mais mais voilà le spectacle était
là on a aussi pu du coup voir quelques
jeunes s'illustrer à ce très haut niveau
je vais parler d'eux
de sébastien vigier et 2010 protégés de
mathilde protéger et melvin dans le
dernier au club de quito près de
montgeron vigneux voilà c'est un garçon
qui vient très régulièrement s'entraîner
s'entraîner au vélodrome c'est quelqu'un
que je connais aussi depuis depuis très
longtemps puisque quand il a préparé ses
premiers championnats de france en
cadets je vais filer un petit coup de
main sur sur la préparation
ils habitent à 500 m de chez moi et du
coup c'était une préparation plutôt pour
les jeunes ou pour les pistards de
l'équipe de france alors oui pardon ça
reste quand même voilà par contre par
ball vous le rappeler à la présence de
sébastien vergé tous ces coureurs je
vais je vais en parler après la
performance de sébastien et d'héroïne
mais pour tous ces coureurs de l'équipe
de france c'est quand même aussi le père
et d'un retrait en cours en compétition
et de répéter les efforts répétés des
bars et on l'a perdue mustapha yann à
cause des courants et de répéter les
efforts parce que les efforts qui sont
produits en compétition ne sont jamais
les mêmes que ceux que l'on peut faire à
l'entraînement il ya aussi l'aspect
tactique que l'on travaille jamais en
complète en contre avec jamais à
l'entraînement quand on estime winter
sur sur piste on ne fait vraiment que du
que du lancer on travaille pas trop trop
la tactique et j'ai vu des très très
beau la malédiction grandeur nature
c'est une groupie de s'ouvre dans la
thur et j'ai vu des beaux gestes des as
beau geste technique de la part d'un
d'un polonais est vraiment très très
sympa il s'appelle un polonais guillaume
donc c'est du business pour les grands
et
c'est du business parce que ça fait
venir du public d'accord donc c'est très
bien
puis ça s'est passé public c'est qu'un
commun c'est de la com et peut-être pas
suffisant peut-être ne sais pas je ne
change rien
qui a raison non mais tout a été dit je
viens pas de raison ou de thor avait
tout a été dit puisque c'est vrai et
guillaume a raison mais yann aussi parce
que oui je peux redire ce qu'ils ont dit
mais c'est vrai c'est à mon avis
sportivement c'est pas une préparation
pour les jo mais c'est plus un rendez
vous pour faire venir un peu de monde
mais en faisant des erreurs comme une
préparation pas dans leur communication
on peut pas faire autrement parce que
vis-à-vis du public on ne peut pas dire
non quand viennent là c'est juste pour
se promener pour se montrer maintenant
il sait pas possible en effet obliger
les y sont bien obligés de dire on vient
pour les préparations pour attirer
attirer le monde et je pense que c'est
plus sain
une compétition de promotion que après
il y avait le poulain de yann donc assez
différent on a quand même vu moi j'ai
discuté avec françois pervis
on a et voilà au niveau des sensations
on se rend bien compte qu'il avait pas
du tout même coup de que qu'à
londres et qu'il est vraiment en train
de revenir et qu'il a énormément
travaillé sur sur les deux mois qui
laisse d'ailleurs on a vu ici viennent
qui vient de passer quoi ça a été
vraiment
c'était vraiment le jour et la nuit
mostafa alors je trouve que les images
parlent d'elles mêmes ce plan de la
compétition on a vraiment l'impression
qu'ils étaient tous venus en touristes
on sentait bien que c'était bon il
fallait être là on est content d'être là
on en voyait bien que c'était pas le
l'élément majeur et structurant de leur
saison et en même temps en même temps
curieusement autour de cette table
souvent on parle de las du manque de
visibilité de certains sports
et quand un événement comme celui-ci on
voudrait boudé son plaisir donc je pense
qu'il faut profiter tout le temps de ce
genre d'événement probablement qu'ils
n'étaient pas à fond parce que tout le
monde connaît bien un peu ça sans rythme
et la manière de se préparer donc oui
sportivement on peut pas dire qu'ils
étaient à fond mais pour le pour le rsa
reste une visibilité ça reste à faire
montrer ce sport ça reste un bon là ça
reste à faire donc je suis bien content
que ces légumes diane on y va à fond sur
ce type de composé de compétition on
voit que malgré baugé qui a été champion
du monde vous assurer que nous est sûr
est que après le repas terminé derrière
votre petit protégé justement sébastien
vigion est ce qu on y va à fond
après la plage la couture votre le
repêchage du tiering vendredi grigory a
dû rester un cas 10 minutes maximum dans
le vélodrome et ils avaient vraiment
vraiment les boules je pense qu'il était
d'après la tradition sérieux ah oui je
pense qu'il était très déçu de m'être
qualifié pour la finale
ah mais c'est passé c'est pas grave non
ça ne change absolument rien sur le
reste il à son programme il est hissé
dans quelle direction il va s'aimer
c'est une étape
le rsa changera rien mais après quand je
veux dire quand on monte sur le vélo
quand on remonte sur le vélo la seule
chose qui comptait quand vous vous jouez
à rendre sur un terrain la seule chose
qu'ils veulent c'est gagné à la fin
d'une compétition s'ils n'ont pas gagné
et bien ils sont déçus l'accord est bien
là et bien là c'était pas qu'on voulait
prendre la prépa après pas peut-être ne
peux te permet pas de gagner à ce moment
là mais ça n'empêche que ça n'empêche
que à la fin du à la sortie du sprint à
la sortie du sprinter mais on l'a bien
vu qu'il était très très déçu beaucoup
moins déçu des zooms wade sud déjà sa
peau et des moniteurs des cieux exe su
mais donnant à des sud est chez des
sujets jeunes et que sais je sais pas je
n'ai pas de discuter avec lui et je
pense pas que grand monde ait pu
discuter avec lui avec lui a bien su ce
qu'il est passé à faire rapidement très
rapidement derrière maintenant ils
étaient beaucoup moins il n'a pas fait
il n'a pas été brillant non plus sur le
sur le tournoi de vitesse mais t'as pas
mustapha qui la met mais on va passer
aux thèmes suivants ducroux jan
je rappelle quand même que la prochaine
étape de la coupe de france fait nuit et
programmées les 8 et 9 juillet à hyères
la dernière manche sera organisée
courant septembre à bourges
vous y serez yann certainement est
certainement hockey oublièrent c'est un
peu plus lourd ok vous nous en verrez
votre planning après cette page coup de
projecteur en passe maintenant la
chronique j'aime j'aime pas de base il a
rigolé
notre chroniqueur base il rigolait nous
présente ces tops et ses flops du
week-end à chaque émission depuis qu'il
fait beau basile rigoli n'est plus sur
ce plateau il est en extérieur elle
profite des rayons du soleil en écoute
son premier jet il concerne le hockey
sur gazon
j'aime la fiche du la finale de
championnat de france de hockey sur
gazon tu auras
qui se disputera dimanche après midi
dans le nord de la france elle opposera
l'équipe saint germanoise du saint
germain ok club à l'équipe versaillaise
du racing club de france pour la
troisième année consécutive les deux
clubs heavy yvelinois vont se retrouver
en finale pour se disputer le titre
il ya deux ans saint germain en laye
l'avait emporté l'an dernier ce sont les
versailles et du racing qui avait
empoché la mise
donc voilà on a le droit à une belle
100% yvelinoise dimanche à douai
guillaume traction par sagem très beau
j'aime mais on se demandait combien ici
aussi un club en france c'est très bien
une cinquantaine de clubs en france et
c'est parfait mais je veux étonner que
racing club de france où l'équipe
versaillaise n'y a pas d'équipé
vertriebs pur de hockey sur gazon je
m'en moquais versailles et ceux basés à
la boulie il est versé y avait une
équipe d'accord 92 il n'y a pas de club
de hockey à versailles d'occasion
versailles et purent enfin au club de
versailles jean sérien là que la bât
serge armand aussi bon on sait très bien
bravo ido les deux équipes ennemies
noiseux les coulisses du racing deux
équipes lilloises qui surtout en finale
d'un sports comme le hockey sur gazon
c'est positif à mustapha oui absolument
enfin je moi j'aime ce genre de
ce genre de sport deux équipes en finale
faut pas l'oublier
on a des images finalement arrivé moi
j'aime voilà le virage est bien sympa
féminin c'est ici c'est pareil c'est
quand même un sport où ça va très vite
et les athlètes les a faites sont sont
de vrais la tête et je pense que
ferait pas les malins même des
footballeurs ne fait pas les malins face
à ce type de maison c'est ce qu'on a
déjà dit yves et surtout au niveau des
genoux et du dos au niveau de la
performance bio c'est magnifique par m
un bon français
mais pardon non c'est non c'est très
bien bas enfin il faut il faut que dans
les régions on est des équipes qu'ils
soient de très haut niveau ce qu'on se
plaint de ne pas avoir des équipes bien
même ce serait bien maintenant l'espoir
minerois en finale du championnat de
france c'est souvent c'est que dans ces
sports antiques ans pour coup saison et
ce point mineur complet on peut que nous
on peut sortir faire de nous des petites
villes dans les villes les premiers
comme versailles une petite ville autour
on peut sortir l'équipe pauliste ifaw de
haut niveau parce que parce que à part
sinon on n'a pas les budgets quoi on n'a
pas les budgets au monde je pense qu'on
n'a pas l'heur à la fin de l'émission on
n'a pas les subventions pour aller
chercher des équipes de haut niveau dans
les sports majeurs quoi donc
donc il faut qu'ils aient des sports
mineurs où on soit ce niveau là c'est
très bien et bravo à eux et je souhaite
ça veut dire qu'on peut le faire on peut
le faire mais voilà on y passe et les
fonderies 15 se poser une petite
question parce que c'est bien je sais
très bien à performante mais c'est la
troisième année consécutive où ils les
deux équipes se retrouvent en finale et
il ya quand même
et oui il ya quand même à mon avis un
problème au niveau de la compétitivité
et programmes pas grand chose en face
saint germain qui gagne oui la troisième
d'affilée it was hollywoodien comme en
europe derrière il y aura également
ils seront peut-être encore plus
généralement il faut quand même à celles
encore assez loin
assez long la finale se jouera le 29 mai
prochain
adou et ici on passe au deuxième jeune
de basile et concerne également envers
sa une cette fois ci à le football
j'aime l'incroyable saison que les
footballeurs du fc versailles en
division d'honneur sont en passe de
réaliser à une journée de la fin du
championnat ils sont deuxièmes avec 80
points
c'est un record dans l'histoire du club
16 victoires au compteur ça n'était
jamais arrivé pour le club de la cité
royale
il y à certaines saisons avec un total
de 80 unités on monte en cfa 2
malheureusement ça suffit rabat créteil
à la réserve de créteil à trois points
d'avancé et et a donc validé à une
journée de la fin sa montée en cfa2
néanmoins coup de chapeau à cette belle
saison dé versailles et à leur
entraîneur youssef chibi pour le travail
réalisé
réaliser la meilleure saison de son
histoire et terminé deuxième et il un
échec
vous votez réalisé la meilleure saison
de son histoire est un mini deuxième est
il un échec
vous votez oui ou non bon vous êtes
unanimes sur la question les gens
pourquoi beaucoup moins sur la question
la pop comme disait coluche parce qu'il
ya d'autres filles 2e d'une compétition
c'est qu'on va tout simplement là mais
l'objectif était la montée est bien sûr
vu comme un plaisir l'objectif c'était
la montée au rugby en en est tombé juste
au bord mais non ce sont peut pas dire
on va dire que c'est une contre
performance
deuxième c'est une belle la meilleure la
meilleure la meilleure saison de leur
histoire avec 16 victoires c'est ça
cette victoire c'est du passé c'est
quand même énorme
c'est quand même énorme on peut pas dire
que ce soit une mauvaise chute et contre
le premier créteil lusitanos
mais voilà donc
ces points cédant quatre heures avant
tout dernière journée il reste il ya
trois points d'écart en réalité c'est
pas le nombre de points qui fait la
différence c'est le goal avérage
particulier d'affaires que ils ont gagné
un match important un nombre de matchs
importants
effectivement il y flotte avant entre le
troisième lyon c'est sais même pas par
rapport à la différence de match mais
indifférence de 2,2 points en goal
avérage particulier même pas au goal
avérage général donc c'est vraiment très
très très très proches
ensuite ça reste leur équipe une face à
une équipe de créteil qui est que la
réserve enfin pardon qui y est la
réserve
je dois vraiment vraiment souligner la
performance du club et de cette équipe
en particulier et de son coach que je
connais bien
pardon ou versailles moi tu fais bien de
prendre sa fille voilà donc connaissant
bien le coach il a fait un travail
remarquable en début de saison il ya eu
beaucoup de gens qui sont partis on sait
d'ailleurs posé la question de savoir
pourquoi il était parti c'est que
c'était un choix du coach plutôt qu'un
un désir ddd joueurs d'aller chercher de
l'amener ailleurs
cela étant le coaching était gagnant le
recrutement a été splendide et on en
voit le résultat
quand quand vous disiez tout à l'heure
si c'est un échec de finir deuxièmes
c'est pas un échec
quand on s'est donné les moyens de
réussir et que finalement on échoue de
si peu c'est une déception
trois points j'en profite pour dire que
par exemple à trappes où nous étions
premier en début de saison voilà les
accidents des accidents d accidents de
la vie vous les connaissez on en a parlé
suffisamment sur cette antenne ont fait
que on échoue la même façon au pied du
podium et j'en profite pour parler des
autres équipes parce qu'on parle souvent
des équipes une
moi j'ai un attachement tout particulier
à l'éducation et aux enfants en
particulier mais ce week-end on a quatre
finales c'est à dire que les u15 et les
u17
la haye la baie et les u17 b finissent
l'année et ça se jouera sur le dernier
match avant dernier match sur le dernier
match
on a donc une possibilité soit de monter
les quatre équipes soi soit on a une
possibilité de d'abord soit on est une
possibilité de faire montre de 4o
quelqu'un on pourra dire qu'on a fait
une saison exceptionnelle soit les 4
pourrait finir deuxième ça serait pas
pour autant en échec parce que pour le
coup ça donne quand vous revenez sur le
côté historique mais également des
jeunes versailles est rapidement est-ce
que avec leur nombre de points dans
d'autres poules de cette même deux
semaines niveau et voilà donc du coup ça
veut dire que ça veut dire est-ce que ça
est ce que ça veut dire que au tirage au
sort des lots pense que si versailles au
rugby dans la foule une de plaisir de
leur maintien
sans vouloir me voilà pour le dernier
volet tirage au sort en début de saison
par sa collègue en même temps je les
félicite et par saison puisque parfois
je vois là et aussi félicité aussi je
sais qu'ils ont deux jeunes cons signé
un contrat en des tout-petits année
moins de deux ans je crois que psg
l'autre avec le stade malherbe de caen
je crois que je vais aussi les pays
cités pour la formation sont partis en
formation
la raison c'est la raison sûr c'est que
sous avoir le meilleur 2e peut être
sélectionnés en fonction des poules et
aimant et là effectivement versée avait
toute sa chance au meilleur deuxième
mais pas en qualité de deuxième version
versailles on continue avec les gemmes
de base et régulier avec le rugby le
rugbyman originaire de saint quentin en
yvelines à clément payan
j'aime la belle histoire qu'il arrive au
rugbyman
clément payen originaire de saint
quentin en yvelines
dans la famille payen on reconnaît yann
thomas les deux frères qui entraîne
cette saison le sky en promotion
d'honneur
on connaissait également maxime qui
était parti à l'âge de
17 ans au stade toulousain et qui évolué
cette année à albi en pro d2 et il ya
également un quatrième frère clément tia
qui n'a pas aspiré à faire une carrière
professionnelle qu'elle joue à massy en
fédérale une qui joue maintenant depuis
six saisons à vannes
et voilà que son club de vannes ce club
breton est promue pour la saison
prochaine en pro d2 donc à 28 ans
clément va va découvrir le monde
professionnel va demander une
disponibilité dans son travail d'une
saison pour pouvoir vivre cette aventure
de la pro d2
guillaume oui qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire cette réussite de la famille
payan et notamment de et clément mais
c'est génial c'est vrai c'est une
famille qui est dans les yvelines en
tout cas ça quentin connu et reconnu
voilà pour leur investissement dans les
différents clubs jusqu'à les rugbys sky
rugby mais avant il se passer à ma six
etarras donc voilà ils ont pu s'en
passer l'anneau la filière de haut
niveau avant et donc bravo à lui dire
j'ai vu ce match vannes contre massy en
montée c'était assez craquant match
superbe par rapport à la finale racing
saracens rien à voir bref et je félicite
aussi au passage le sky donc les deux
frères qui entraîne le sky puisqu'ils
sont en quarts de finale soit france
promotion d'honneur qui joueront ce
dimanche qui joue ce dimanche là donc
bravo à eux aussi pour la saison même si
mon de jarnac 1 je crois c'est vrai il y
manque pas non plus je crois enfin pas
pour l'instant en tout cas effectivement
et donc aussi bravo voilà genre vous
connaissez vous clément payan nomme pas
personnellement
personnellement lorsque je connais pas
je sais qu'il est qu'il est du coin et
qu'il a été formé à massy
il a fait un passage à massy c'est à
concevoir ou pas guy voilà
jouer à vals notamment joueurs quand
même fédéral une haut du tableau
bon club de vannes ça peut être qu'un
beau jour on joue pas en effet domino
comme ça vous l'avez jouer et comment
dis pas que je veuille ou non je sais
quoi je la famille paye un inconnu après
voilà moi j'ai jamais été les voir si la
famille oui mais je le court mais après
les livres tous les frangins enfin tous
les frères la fratrie ont tous joué dans
la filière de haut niveau jaune toute
façon dont on connaît un qui perd ses
dents parmi tous et tous ses frères
c'est je veux dire c'est une vraie c'est
presque normal l'aboutissement de
l'investissement aussi de la famille
entière coiffe un des parents et sert à
quoi ça vous inspire vous cédez fratrie
comme ça des fois ça peut être ben
génétique comme on en parlait avec
comment et où le ja non non moi je
parlais de teddy riner voilà c'est un
peu génétique le garçon il est hors
norme physiquement donc là-bas peut-être
que en effet les parents ont des petits
ont des petites près ses prédispositions
pour ça après ben voilà
un investissement à long terme on
apprend des échecs des uns et des autres
et puis au bout d'un moment on arrive à
en sortir et c'est tout le travail d'un
coach est là bas voilà ça reste dans le
cercle familial dans le vélo on connaît
ça parce que c'est des sports où on dit
qu'on est vacciné avec un rayon donc
donc voilà ça fait partie de mes combats
que ça oui voilà nous comptons donc
voilà des fratries comme ça ça existe et
frère simon les frères simon qui ont
tous gagné une étape du tour de france
par exemple la famille simon dans leurs
vélos des femmes et on parle de fratrie
on parle de fratries donc voila voila
donc ça arrive ça arrive ça arrive
souvent et donc tant mieux pour eux
parce que c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose de ces quelque chose de bien après
allez j'aime de basilan passe au jaune
paille concerne l'équipe de football
américain des templiers à del en cours
j'aime pas les résultats
très décevant cette saison de l'équipe
de football américain les templiers
d'elancourt
alors que les dirigeants s'étaient
montrés ambitieux avec un projet sur
quelques années deux pour aller chercher
une place en play-offs tout d'abord
cette saison puis voir le titre dans les
deux ans à venir aimable europe dans
trois ou quatre ans voilà que la
mayonnaise dans le groupe entre les
anciens et les nouveaux n'a pas n'a pas
pris les résultats sont bien en deça
avec une seule victoire au compteur
avant d'aborder cette dernière journée
de championnat
les templiers vont recevoir les cougars
samedi soir les champions de france en
titre pour un match décisif
tout autre résultat qu'une victoire
condamnerait les élans courtois à
retourner en d2 l'an prochain ce qui
serait une grosse désillusion par
rapport aux aux ambitions et aux moyens
qui avait été mis en place en début de
saison mais de retour en plateau avec
guillaume 09 qui a changé de tenue voilà
on voit qu'il a écrit en polo maintenant
c'est une catastrophe pour les templiers
d'elancourt si le club descend la saison
et je vous l'annoncé on va au moins
catastrophe ont remarqué jean contre
royal n'ont jamais commencé une
catastrophe quatre à cinq rotations
c'est vraiment une catastrophe
c'est un constat je dirais pas une
catastrophe c'est m costa bon je passe
ici avec un ami les moyens mais qu'ils
avaient recruteurs n'avait pas réussi ce
plateau quarterbacks américain
franco-canadien américaine qui avait
joué un des clubs les normes belges
ah non mince un américain qui s'appelle
justin riddick hilti receveur mais
raconte il avait également un
quarterback qui était d'origine
canadienne voilà donc voilà il est beau
et avec un mis les moyens il était allé
chercher des gens qui étaient qui était
de la partie on va dire apparemment la
mayonnaise n'a pas pris quoi
donc il faut peut-être se met tirer les
enseignements de ce qu'ils aient ce qui
est arrivé cette saison pour mieux
rebondir la saison prochaine
c'est vrai que quand vous dites qu'ils
avaient des prétentions heureusement
qu'ils avaient des prétentions
quand on va chercher des joueurs de
cette trempe pour essayer de bien
figurer dans le championnat et qu'on
échoue forcément il faut en tirer les
bonnes conclusions notamment au niveau
de la direction du club
je suis ferme assez étonné parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'à saison elle a
commencé il ya quinze jours trois
semaines de recours donc je vais mal
février voilà donc oui ben il ya quinze
jours trois semaines à peu près on est
enregistrée et donc dont qua non je
trouve que ça va ça va quand même très
très vite et on a très peu le temps de
ce pouvoir se rattraper en cas de manque
à paris on en parle on en a déjà parlé
avec mustapha c'est vrai que nous a pas
dit où c'est possible sur les matches
aller de finir dernier d'un d'être
dernier après les faibles à la phase des
matches aller et de pouvoir se refaire
sur la deuxième phase est de venir et
devenir champion champion enfin deux en
fin de saison
là j'ai l'impression que la phase 2 le
championnat il a commencé il ya trois
émissions sportives aux mineurs qui
rêvent mais la clé on est d'accord ça va
très vite ça n'empêche que voilà ça va
très vite et où il ya quand même pas
beaucoup de temps pour pouvoir se
rattraper en cas de en cas de mauvais
départ attention si la saison n'est pas
terminée il ya également les playoffs
bien sûr les temps pin partie directe
des rallyes pour les indirects je monte
donc maintenant voilà
bah ouais dommage dommage pour eux
maintenant s'ils arrivent à conserver
l'esprit que l'effectif peut-être qu'ils
pourront faire comme les filles du chéné
et descendre remonter bien sûr que c'est
un échec gens déjà faire il ya ils vont
chercher des mecs qualifié à des postes
d accord ne soit que ces pays arrive pas
alors j'ai tout fait que c'est avec les
mots pas les garder se passe mal et leur
ligue
il leur faut il leur faut faire prendre
peut-être un petit peu plus de temps un
peu plus de temps pour faire prendre la
mayonnaise
s'ils arrivent à conserver l'effectif
bien les prochaines en indivision ils
vont ils vont ils vont remonter aussitôt
et puis et puis ça pour alors maintenant
on sait aussi
on sait aussi utiles sont appréciés de
formation voilà j'allais venir ils ont
aussi un projet de formation peut-être
que ça va être l'étape qui va leur
permettre de faire rentrer plus de
jeunes et qui pourront justement leur
servir en 2018 parce que là
là ça n'a pas fonctionné cette année par
contre moustapha en deuxième division
ils attireront sûrement plus
d'américains arrivée nature ont d'autant
moins c'est pour ça que j'ai répondu que
c'était catastrophique même si le mot
est fort c'est une déception pour le
club et en même temps oui sert qu'à
chaque fois que vous descendez c'est à
la fois les vos propres joueurs que vous
pouvez perdre préfère vous n'êtes pas
cette force d'attraction des autres donc
séances axa qui parle c'est en ça que
c'est compliqué et probablement contre
cette table on sera d'accord avec moi
sur le sujet mais cela étant on a parlé
beaucoup de cuisine pour parler sport
c'est quand même le titre de l'émission
la mayonnaise c'est une chose la
mayonnaise c'est un tour de main et on
l'a où on l'a pas on se donne le temps
des ingrédients on les a pas dans le
sport il ya quand même une notion de
temps qui est quand même importante
voilà ça n'a pas pris cette fois ci mais
voilà ce sont le temps donc qu'on
jugeait un club on a parlé des
dirigeants tout à l'heure ils ont un
rôle éminemment important
je me situe souvent à ce niveau là c'est
une part importante du sport ne pensons
pas que ces résidents étaient là la
dernière fois et il est pas présent
cette fois ci il était venu à la limite
c'était déjà c'était déjà annoncé une
façon habile mais c'est vrai que on a
tendance à mettre beaucoup de beaucoup
de poids sur les équipes ce sont elles
qui jouent ce sont elles qui font les
performances mais il ya tout un
environnement qui est très important
aussi
ça sera le mot de la fin avec vous ses
tapas ont continué cette émission ans
par notre rubrique débats
le boxeur de la team farrugia à marvin
petit sera souvent aussi à 27 mai sur le
ring du cirque d'hiver de paris à
l'occasion de la soirée baptisée lé
prince du ring le sportif élan courtois
affrontera cette occasion dame seck
originaire de corbeil-essonnes
non content de préparation vue d'un
championnat d'europe prévu normalement
en novembre l'objectif annoncé par le
boxeur nous l'avions reçues sur le
bateau 17,8 sport le 23 mai dernier le
championnat d'europe puis le champion du
monde c'est ça votre prochaine échéance
est exactement c'est aller au but de
hope you quoi johann roques chevalier
championnat du monde j'espère à jouer
d'être champion du monde champion de
france pour l'instant ça ne vous
concerne plus âgés la chine titre je
vais plus longtemps par les plus du tout
maintenant ça sera aux repères au niveau
mondial européen et mondial
je suis pressé dans les 2e but donc
maintenant je pense aller je pense que
j'ai ma chance pour aller au bout chou
pas d'europe
marvin petit marmite qui veut se
reconcentrer sur les championnats
d'europe
est ce que c'est une bonne solution la
question ce thème doit-on privilégier un
titre européen un titre de champion de
france
votez enfin petit duel gens contre
moustapha un genre vous amuser avec y
aller il ya des gens bien des gens je
suis jayan je suis le seul à les ia tôt
avoir été plusieurs fois champion de
france et avoir des champions d'europe
voilà et dont je sais en sport en sport
mais en même temps vous allez si on
donne le choix entre être champion de
france
mianné et champion d'europe la même
année eh bien mon choix se pose pas
assez baissé
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux laisser tomber
un titre de champion de france pour
devenir champion d'europe
c'est ça la question voilà voilà et bien
donc moi je dis moi je dis oui plus et
enfin le sport c'est fait pour aller
chercher la plus haute performance et
pourra chercher les plus beaux combats
les plus beaux matchs les plus beaux
titres et bien donc moi oui bien sûr que
je lâche un type de champion de france
pour aller chercher pour aller chercher
un titre de champion du monde
bien sûr maintenant n'ont même pas mal
atteint cela sera championne d'europe 1
oui mais je la
oui bien sûr mais je comprends bien et
tapas restait de bastet étape par étape
le problème pour moi il a complètement
raison de dire j'abandonne ce titre je
prépare mon titre de champion d'europe
et je dis tu manges devrait pas mon
combat pour aller chercher un titre de
champion d'europe
il a il est complètement dans le vrai
bien sûr là les gens alors je vais te
répondre aujourd'hui
oui oui le fait le fait qu'il veuille ça
c'est sûr c'est certain c'est plus
intéressant petit toit champenois
maintenant maintenant est ce qu il al
expérience vraiment est ce qu'il a
acquis assez d'expérience pour aller
vraiment me faire ce championnat
d'europe
parce que s'il fait comme l'autre boxeur
contre l'anglais j'ai pu se nommer ou
matisse voilà s'il fallait en partie les
teamfights jamais ma life est il fait
partie de la même équipe ça j'ai bien
remarqué
s'il fait le même championnat d'europe
que lui et qui tiennent qui tiennent pas
longtemps et qu'il en prend plein le
museau je sais pas si si si le jeu en
vaut la chandelle
est-ce que je ne connais pas son
parcours à ce berceau mais est ce qu il
a à ses acquis d'expérience il a été
nationalisée deux fois champion de
france il avait battu et sylvain
chapelle en décembre dernier il avait
perdu son titre parce qu'il avait laissé
vacant tout simplement
et il avait également gagné le titre en
2013 donc été deux fois champion il fait
le saviez et 9h en approche donc c'est
bien ce que je dis là jours jouaient ce
que je dis est ce qu'il a vraiment
l'expérience pour aller pour aller
titiller le niveau européen je ne suis
pas sûr quand même un jeune sur deux
fois qui combat pour être simple deux
fois qu'il est champion de france vient
un moment où il a perdu leur âme c'est
le trait il a perdu une fois le titre de
champion des landes et les expositions
laisser vacant et la première fois il
avait perdu il avait perdu mais il ya un
moment où il ya un moment où c'est
normal quand tu es d'accord là mais n'a
jamais joué à naples et oui bien sûr
donc à temps c'est ce sport aux enfin je
comprends parce que dans tous les sports
de combat judo ce qu'on veut mais non
mais on fait chaud pas de france pas
d'europe du monde et olympique est là
monsieur mais déjà il déjà champion de
france est alors teddy riner l'état il
n'a pas semblé actuellement non mais les
athlètes de haut niveau ils sont
champions de france que maintes fois ça
va un peu trop
il faut trop nombreux européens
incombait internationale pressée par le
temps mais après fait ce qu'il veut moi
sommes deux mais je souhaite tout étonné
qu'à la boxe on puisse dire à un moment
donné pendant les repas de france ça
m'intéresse plus toute façon mais je
vais faire autre chose mais si je vois
ces images je pars du principe que un
sport un sport tas laissons pas de
france tous les ans il se bat à derrida
rock sound et fillon défis et puis à ce
programme trois mois à la main ça
l'ancien enclos en cinq ans et voilà
tout ce que ça fait bien sûr nommé c'est
ça c'est comme l escrime tu ne refuse
pas le duel d'ingérence raison pour
l'europe tous les ensembles sont deux
champions olympiques tous les quatre ans
l'étonnante afin qu'ils puissent comme
ça a dit ronald et benoît gillet
pachkova de france je me concerne je
trouve ça étonnant
moi je comprends je comprends qu'il ait
envie d'aller chercher plus haut virer
voilà et donc et bien qu'ils essayent et
il verra s'il est capable d'aller les
chercher ou pas il va certainement avoir
des matches il va certainement avoir des
matches de préparation pour pouvoir
aller à queue pour pouvoir à laquelle
l'expérience suffisante pour pour le
combat pour le combat politique
voilà mon souhait mais tu peux faire
encore un mot de la fin guillaume allait
déjà été jeté comme il a déjà été
humilié par titre d'après lui cela ne
gâche pas d'europe champion d'europe
champion national et voilà on passe
maintenant au deuxième scène de ce débat
on souhaite en tout cas bon courage et à
marvin petit qu'on va traire du coup ce
vendredi au cirque d'hiver après la boxe
on va retenir notre souffle nous allons
parler d'apnée ce dimanche 22 mai andy
cabreira avia à cuba apnéistes de 45 ans
a battu un record du monde en apnée
il a parcouru 17 km et 350 m le sportif
a donc effacé le record de pascal maes
et le français avait effectué à 9,3 km
en février dernier on écoute
andy cabreira à bien mon objectif
c'était de faire 6 5 à 3 longueurs
ça fait dix-sept kilométrique poil et il
dépassait des 680 14 longueurs donc je
veux atteindre les 700 mais au niveau
physiologique dieu dû m'arrêter pour
aller aux toilettes
deux fois et donc c'est obligé mais
sinon je suis mais je suis très content
très heureux
il n'y a rien à regretter au contraire
de remercier tout le monde des morts
ceux tenus dans cette aventure
cette performance est clipsé tels les
autres sports les autres résultats du
week-end dans le département vous votez
je parle bien sûr de la difficulté en
difficulté la difficulté de le saisir
par des difficultés
un petit duel entre guillaume eliane la
revanche a légué si on parle de la
difficulté en effet c'est un record de
moins qui est incroyable puisqu'il
fallait failli mais ne pas une lune
dollars cordes à vent y'a pas de soucis
après faut que je préciser que c'est
tout les temps je sais papa le 25 mai
dans palier de 24 ans parce que des
stylos mais c'est beaucoup quand même
et maintenant alors s'ils n'ont pas de
difficulté bien sûr que c'est un super
record maintenant c est ça avec ça ça
prend toute la mesure de la turinoise
sur les sports pinoit
maintenant si l'on parle de
médiatisation et je trouve que ça n'a
aucun intérêt
vous allez pour moi c'est un sport
mineur bien sûr encore une fois vous
connaissez bien ce sport
bah oui sa vie dans sa baignoire le
connais bien non vous avez des petites
un très bon copain à moi et qui est
notamment en méditerranée voilà est qui
et qui est médaille de bronze au
championnat du monde en 2015 donc voilà
je connais un petit peu l'apnée geipan
je me suis prêt toujours pas essayer ça
viendra ça viendra un jour mais donc
voilà je sais le
la préparation sa demande le
l'investissement que les les apnéistes
peuvent peuvent avoir et qui peut aussi
le parcours de ce
de ceux de ceux de cet homme qui a fui
qui a fui le régime d'après ce que
j'avais à comprendre voilà c'est fait
rage ouais non non pas la nage mais bon
voilà les parties de cuba avec sa fille
enfin voilà ça y était c'était c'est
assez compliqué pour pour cet homme
il a une vie il a une vie un peu il
abrite en amérique du sud
et puis et puis là et puis le fait aussi
pour il l'a fait aussi pour une noble
cause il le fait il a fait pour une pour
une petite fille qui est qui et qui est
malade donc c'est voilà il ya aussi un
côté à côté
dumas ni toi là et donc donc du coup
c'est vrai que c'est une très belle
performance
c'est une très belle performance et il y
en a 11 ans j'invite j'invite tout le
monde dimanche prochain quand ils vont
week-end prochain quand ils vont à la
piscine d'essayer de faire 25 mètres en
apnée juste une longueur et il cotait
voilà d'accord mais après la pâle apnée
comme moi j'entends l'apnée c'est tarnac
ne tuerez ce temps là je descends qui
respire pas là tu respires pas quoi
mettre un tout petit le fait de faire de
l'apnée repreneur sa liste des 25 mètres
en même temps pas tous en même temps
maintenant il ya des records d'apnée qui
sont sur la longueur aussi par exemple
vous aviez xavier c'est près de 300
mètres d'apnée
autour d'un autour d'un carré en mer en
mer et donc donc voilà c'est donc on va
chercher aussi la distance sur sur la
longueur à trouver intérêt du record de
l'avoir prise de respiration
je trouve que ça c'est comme un conte à
contre courant ce rapport à la fne quoi
durant ces essais d'endurance mais si on
appelait d'accord c'est comme ça c'est
comme faire 24 heures de roller sur le
circuit bugatti tout seul pendant ces
cds record d'endurance tout simplement
sa femme met tout le monde d'accord
c'est un record tout ça comment faire
quand on connaît les règles au départ
moi je mets au défi qui que ce soit dans
cette table de le faire on connaît les
conditions c'est que ce sont des
longueurs de 25 tu t'arrêtes autant de
temps que tu veux tu prends ta
respiration autant de temps que tu veux
sauf que ça reste très cadré donc dans
ce cadre là c'est un record maintenant
où guillaume a raison c'est que en gros
en gros tout le monde s'en fout je pense
que c'est plutôt à ça qui faisait
référence
on parlait de visibilité tout à l'heure
on parle de sport mineur et les
audiences est de plus en plus et de plus
en plus on descend au fond de la piscine
en termes de en termes de visibilité au
niveau des sports moi c'est ce que j'ai
retenu mais c'est vrai que par rapport à
la performance en est une puisqu'on
avait un ancien record et qu'il est
battu dans des conditions encore une
fois qu'ils sont dans des conditions qui
sont cadrés et donc c'est une
performance
en tous les cas pour la science c'est
important genre ils sont durs ouais ils
sont très durs très durs nous savons
c'est 16 pour mineurs moi j'ai un copain
qui était championne du monde de las et
d'espadrilles
bon et fraîche main histoire vraie c'est
une histoire c'est une histoire vraie ce
qui les fuit depuis ce qu'on voit là on
a des images mais parce que les images
mais pas les yvelines quand même
il est pas désigné basque compliqué mais
voilà mais bon il faut qu'il rende
maintenant parce que c'est pas ces pages
à dix qui disent c'est comme une très
grande performance et c'est sûr nous
attend quand même pour la petite fille
la petite fille quand même inquiet elle
aussi je crois me fait d'ailleurs de la
base c'est son élève a dit en passant
c'est trop tard non mais on n'a pas dit
ça je le dis que c'est une performance
sportive est certes très simplement mais
que scientifiques sportives pour tous
après ce débat nous avons passé au
traditionnel défi du jour
le défi concerne aujourd'hui le rugby
les joueurs de versailles se sont prêtés
au jeu
le but quatre joueurs de l'équipe
s'affrontent ils doivent aller le plus
vite possible sur une courte distance
regardez je sais antoine 23 ans au rugby
club de versailles depuis 2011 surnom du
sla du c'est petit si une favoris comme
ça damien verstraete
j'ai 24 ans a fait 16 ans que je au club
depuis l'an 2000 et mon surnom chez dams
est le signe c'est la chose victor
chauvet je suis à versailles depuis un
an seulement et mon sont annoncés et
brooke thibault cause je suis au
rugby-club de versailles depuis depuis
sept ans donc des plus depuis 2009 et
mon surnom on m'appelle cause
ouais
à
oh
en fait
sûr parce que je pensais que d'amener ma
mère chantal hier allez on peut plus
tenir le manche est en finale et groupe
stone rosso sous ses abords c'est cool
de faire des petits dépit des filles
comme ça ça change un peu des des
entraînements en plus la commune six ans
vient de terminer ça fait là ça
s'annonce un peu l'été donc c'est cool
sympa
genre une réaction par rapport à cet
exploit à une action il si guillaume qui
me disait je comprends mieux pourquoi
ils m'ont club descend si ce sont les
quatre plus rapide du club
néanmoins j'avais trouvé le vecteur au
départ le petit tout en rouge j'avais
dit non tu manges c'était normal non
mais savent aussi qu'elles aient gagné
le étonné aussi que que brooks ont un
final mais bon damien s'est échappé au
bon peu importe c'est utile ou qu'ils
aient gagné parce que c'est un des plus
rapides du club système plus rapide en
tout cas sur les courtes distances
ça donne des idées pour le vélo ça c'est
bien prochain essai en vo go et bravo
thibout rythme on apprend enfin on passe
à présent au coup de gueule darlot le
gouic
vous en avez désormais à l'habitude
notre chroniqueur arnaud logo ical alias
le grinch yves binois pousse un coup de
gueule sur le dépôt sport dans le
département chaque émission aujourd'hui
arnaud qui est toujours très remonté va
nous parler est des subventions pour les
clubs locaux écouter
merci michael aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler gros sous et finances fasse je
veux vous parler
j'aurais aimé vous parler puisque en
fait je vous parlais des subventions ont
été votées par les par les villes lors
de leurs budgets très très récemment et
qui sont en baisse notamment pour les
clubs sportifs
ça pose problème puisqu'il est que
largement de ces subventions en ont
besoin et ça les met en danger puisque
c'est pas la première année ça
s'explique par le contexte un peu
compliqué économiquement que connaît le
pays
je trouve ça dommage que les villes face
justement le choix de baisser ses
subventions
ça peut avoir un effet néfaste aussi
pour les villes puisque les clubs
participent à l'attractivité d'une ville
sa réputation à la vie tout simplement
des gens et ils sont déjà unis vivent
déjà une crise du bénévolat depuis
quelques années c'est compliqué de
trouver des gens pour s'occuper des
associations si en plus on commence à
leur couper les vivres ça va devenir
très compliqué je suis pas sûr que ça
soit un bon choix pour les villes de
laisser les subventions c'est mon avis
moustapha quelle est votre réaction par
rapport à ce coup de gueule alors les
supports les subventions accordées par
les communes son public donc la mienne
l'est tout autant la subvention de la
ville de trappes par exemple elle n'a
pas bougé
donc je suis obligé de venir parce que
là encore une fois c'est public et on
peut s'y référer depuis trois ans j'ai
signé un contrat de l'objectif avec la
commune de train et voilà c'est le choix
qu'ont appris entre la ville et notre
club c'est encore une fois ce sont des
deniers publics
on a des comptes à rendre nous recevons
des subventions nous avons également des
comptes à rendre
c'est pas simplement qu'on doit réclamer
de l'argent aux villes pour faire
fonctionner le sport moi je considère
que nous président de clamer présidents
d'associations on a également des
comptes à rendre sur ses deniers publics
et sur l'investissement des
contribuables
donc il ya un contrat d'objectifs entre
la commune et - entre la commune et nous
pendant trois ans ça n'a pas bougé qu'on
verra plus tard mais à ce jour je dois
le dire ça n'a pas bougé
ça c'est le premier point le second
point ce sont des ddd des subventions
qui sont alloués au club
alors c'est vrai que ça participe à
l'attractivité des villes à visiter des
villes bref à l'image et la notoriété
alors les ans alors oui bien sûr qu'il a
raison mais là il s'adresse à
probablement d'autres communes que celle
d'autres apps puisque par définition ça
n'a pas bougé et c'est là où il a
effectivement raison on ne doit pas
détruire ce genre de tissu associatif et
donc il faut y faire très attention mais
je ne sais pas si c'est sur le plan
communal que c'est le plus tragique un
la communauté d'agglomération a retiré
du fait que ça ne soit pas sa compétence
à retirer des subventions
classe sportive mais là on a parlé de
compétences donc si la compétence de la
communauté n'est plus il ya plus de
subventions eu égard à ce set
cette méthode est à cette manière de
présenter les choses
les communes elles normalement doivent
faire de sorte que les idées c'est le 4
a par exemple dire une réaction ben
c'est pas le cas ce versailles à
versailles ils ont besoin les
subventions de toutes tous les assauts
sauf durant je crois ce qui était
vraiment très bas de 4 5%
toutes les assauts sont élevées ces
mêmes fins le foot au rugby le rendre le
basket
bref peu importe et c'est vrai que pour
les budgets des clubs c'est c'est une
baisse cam qui est qui qui est difficile
parce qu'aujourd'hui on sait très bien
que les pour qu'un club dit il faut des
suivants fin il faut de l'argent quand
il fait des subventions il faut des
partenariats layrac l'avocat ne peut pas
vivre sans subvention alors impossible
impossible impossible on peut pas
trouver des partenaires non n'est pas
feint on n'est pas en l'occurrence n'est
pas assez attractif justement par
rapport à notre niveau de jeu enfin
notre niveau 2 d'exposition soit presse
presse télé ou radio etc
et du coup nous sommes des partenaires
viennent que 6 et enfin enfin à
versailles doit plaisir je pense que
c'est pareil c'est lui c'est du réseau
du copinage et c'est du mécénat quoi
c'est pas du partenariat vraiment où en
charge de la rentabilité quoi donc nous
un haut niveau peut pas s'en sortir
uniquement des partenaires privés il
nous faut des partenaires publics et la
mairie forcément est le principal et
voilà donc on a besoin de cet argent
pour vivre en jean très rapidement 20
secondes
bah oui je lui en ai tout dit les clubs
ont besoin de subventions et le pas le
partenariat doit venir en complément et
non pas en priorité
après le partenariat dans un club quel
qu'il soit ça prend énormément de temps
et il faut beaucoup de monde de pot sans
occuper ce sera le mot de la fin c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve dans 15 jours
le jeudi 9 juin pour un nouveau numéro
de six ans par les sports n'oubliez pas
que vous pouvez regarder l'émission
nouveau sur notre site internet et sur
youtube
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78